boris johnson's due to speak by phone to
the president of the european commission
in the next half hour ahead of his
self-imposed deadline for walking away
from post-brexit
trade talks the prime minister's
previously said he wants to know if a
trade deal is possible by tomorrow
when the leaders of the 27 eu countries
meet
in brussels well i'm joined now from
brussels by our europe correspondent
adam parsons and
in the studio by our deputy political
editor sam coats
thanks for joining me both of you to you
first of all adam this cool dude take
place in the next half an hour ahead of
this big summit
what is the prime minister really hoping
to hear from ursula wonderland
well i'm sure he would love to hear that
there is a deal around the corner he
isn't going to hear that
at all i've spoken to multiple eu
sources today from
inside these institutions and also from
member states and not
one of them thinks that a brexit deal
is frankly anywhere near what they all
say
is that they want to deal but not at any
price they say that there are still the
same sticking points around
the level playing field governance and
of course uh
fishing and so i think when ursula von
de leon and charles michelle the
president of the european council speak
to boris johnson
they're going to say that they want a
deal but they need some compromise from
both sides particularly around
around fishing and around governance and
they'll wait to see what comes back
in the other direction but i think when
the leaders come
here they will put out a statement
afterwards uh
saying that talks need to intensify
we've heard that happen
multiple times already but i should say
that the talks between britain and the
european commission have now wrapped up
for this week we expect them to carry on
next week as long of course
as mr johnson doesn't pull the rug he
does face another challenge though
which is that brexit frankly isn't at
the top
of the agenda in the minds of almost any
european states
as i'm talking to you emmanuel macron
the french president is just wrapping up
an address to the nation
and he has announced a curfew for paris
in eight
other cities running from nine o'clock
in the evening through to
six in the morning this is pretty
swinging restrictions you'll get
fined if you are out at night and why
because he sees a soaring rate of
coronavirus
there also we're seeing that in the
czech republic here in belgium even in
germany which copes so well
with the first wave that is what is
dominating the opinions
of many many leaders yes they want a
deal
but it's not at any cost and it is not
their number one priority okay adam
thank you or sam given what adam was
just saying there the
agenda not only for our european
counterparts but boris johnson
as well the clock is ticking what does
all of this mean
for the possibility of no deal it
remains according to downing street very
much on the table look as adam said
we get the same script this side of the
english channel as well uh that the
talks uh still have significant
differences uh at their core
uh on issues uh like level playing field
state aid
uh and uh fishing now there are plenty
uh
in parliament in the conservative party
and in cabinet that think that if the
route only comes down
really to fishing then that's actually a
signal that we're on course for a deal
but there's quite a disconnect uh
between
what's going on in negotiations and
frankly even some cabinet ministers
while cabinet ministers tell me they're
certain that we're going to end up
uh getting a deal there are those uh
closer to the talks that say even this
week although some technical progress
was made
it isn't going extremely well and i
think it is that business
just as in brussels as also in london uh
that coronavirus has pushed this uh
issue of brexit
further down the agenda frankly tonight
uh down history is having to weigh up
whether or not to
follow the instructions of scientists to
shut down and impose restrictions on
large parts of the north of england that
is much more at the top of downing
street's
uh uh mind that means that some of the
more complicated issues around brexit
just aren't
being sorted out and there's no clear
way through
so where does that leave us well i think
on the issue of brexit there are
differences that look hard to reconcile
and we will have to wait until friday
now not tomorrow
to find out whether or not boris johnson
is going to continue the talks
further into october but when you look
at other issues that are also weighing
on boris johnson's mind most notably
that extraordinary poll out of scotland
suggesting that 58 of people up there
would now vote for independence versus
42
vote for the union and whether or not a
no deal brexit might weigh
in that argument as well then perhaps
the calculation about just how far boris
johnson might move starts to change